boa tarde
é um tema confissão um eu tenho vício 1
sobre se a do inferno
não posso andar na cidade uma
barraquinha com tomate alface eu já vou
indo doutorado em ciência política
só que hoje eu sou o organismo feiras
para feira todo final de semana pouco
tempo viajei pra europa como namorada e
não conseguir não conseguir não me
contive aconteceu em uma feira uma feira
de rua turca uma feira de fazendeiros
locais
uma feira de café uma feira
já esqueci mas já chegou na quinta feira
falou amor está tudo bem vamos fazer um
programa claro vamos o mercado vai num
toque hoje mutirão da brincadeira agora
pra falar de um projecto que acredita
numa feira e nas pessoas que juntos se
juntaram
através dessa feira um projeto pra mudar
a maneira como a gente come uma coisa
tão importante e tão pouco discutida que
a colhida em várias feiras e essa é uma
delas é que fazendo um fato de tomate
ano mas que é tão fascinante que é tão
legal das feiras né
não só do ponto de vista de quem é
apaixonado por comida mas o ponto de
vista de quem é um cidadão que é o mundo
melhor
a feira é um local que historicamente se
constituiu como se cravou na cidade como
local entre em que a natureza o campo
começou a dialogar com a cultura e com a
cidade
então lá feira você tinha os fazendeiros
chegando pescadores chegando às donas de
casa
hoje em dia o chefe dizendo pra ele e
forjando as nossas tradições alimentares
e isso baseado naquilo que tinha que
estava adaptado ao solo ao clima ao
conhecimento disponível então é uma é
além disso hoje em dia principalmente é
um é o lugar também da cidade o que você
conhece seu bairro a cidade às pessoas
que moram lá você vai na feira você
conhece seu vizinho
você troca de idéias como a senhora que
passa uma receita você aprende muito
você aprende a saber quanto que o peixe
está bom quanto que uma fruta está no
auge do do primo você aprende todas as
estações
isso pra mim é tudo muito fascinante
só que tem um problema é as feiras estão
tomou vendo esse aqui é o típico mercado
municipal do rio de janeiro um prédio
indo hoje em dia é essa só a torre del
mar o que nos resta
hoje fazemos compras em supermercados
aí eu tenho que encontrar outro vício é
e eu gosto eu tenho uma compulsão por
ler rótulos embalagens
eu entro de mercado para comprar um pote
de requeijão saiu duas horas depois do
tremendo talento mercado não deixa de
ser fascinante é um aprendizado mas que
a gente está aprendendo no supermercado
onde está aprendendo as vezes que a
ficar colorida não necessariamente feita
por pessoas é feita por empresas é feita
é focando no no sabor mais interessante
na conveniência na praticidade e pra mim
é isso me incomoda muito você perde um
pouco aquela aquela coisa vibrante da
ver aquele contato direto aquele
aprendizado muito rico que você tem a
diversidade a peculiaridade da feira é
substituída no mercado por uma coisa
pasteurizada pela luz de neon
hoje em dia os supermercados estão cada
vez mais parecidos você percorre as
fileiras tempo parece ter muita coisa
mas se você for ler os rótulos você tem
99% de ingredientes iguais mordam
aqueles nomes ingleses que existe no
final geralmente são as coisas que dão o
sabor e eu estou fazendo essa essa
confissão em falando um pouco sobre
supermercados não só porque o passo
muito tempo esses locais
digamos pesquisando porque eu acho que
essa esse contraste é uma alegoria muito
boa que fala muito sobre está
acontecendo com um agente com a maneira
como a gente come e isso por sua vez com
a nossa sociedade e nossa nação se
comporta em relação a isso né
o famoso filósofo francês arranque é
sempre citado ele e ligeiramente mais
citado por ele diz a medida que commerce
direito em áreas mas ele não tem outra
frase que as pessoas não sintam tanto
que é o destino das nações é determinado
pela maneira como elas alimentam seu
povo e como é que está alimentando
nossos povos quem está alimentando o
povo quer que você está vendo no mercado
não tá vendo ninguém já colhida é um bem
importante a comida cultura comida
identidade comida conexão à natureza a
comida cada um se apropria dela de uma
maneira mas ela é uma coisa que eu
lembro a todos e esse diagnóstico sobre
a crise por assim dizer se alimentar
ela não é novidade vários estudiosos
jornalistas bem fazendo isso ea gente
poderia caor horas debatendo ela mas eu
acho que talvez uma das explicações é um
dos argumentos mais elegantes foi feito
por esse simpático careca chamado
michael pollan que eu também chamo de
jesus sobre o cozinhar
ele descreve o processo é que a gente
parou de cozinha nas últimas décadas
porque em nome da conveniência em
loureda da emancipação do trabalho
agentes especiais
sá né nos nossos trabalhos né a gente
tem mais tempo a gente parou de cultivar
o primeiro momento e parou de cozinhar e
é isso também é quando você vai na feira
o barato não voltando pro barato né o
barato é só você ver aquelas verduras e
lindas radiantes ele o barato você levar
aquilo pra casa uma barata você decidiu
que vai fazer com aquilo dali que vou
fazer você tem que aprender a cozinhar
depois você cozinha o que fazer com
aquele monte de comida porque não me
contive comprei toda a feira atrai como
você vai compartilhar aquilo com seus
amigos com sua família e nesse processo
do sistema alimentar cujas motivações
não vou não vou ficar discutindo agora
mas o fato é que paramos de comer comida
feita por pessoas na companhia de
pessoas
epá começamos a comprar comida feita por
empresas e ambientes que são controlados
por empresas
então na questão é essencial para uma
questão de pesquisa também isso começou
a incomodar e procurar comecei a
procurar soluções e quando eu quero
aprender mais
eu vou pra feira aí eu fui pra feira
conversei com o feirante adilson adilson
já que essa comida você sabe eu não
comprei do estado ceasa tem uma coisa
que eu não sei mas a maioria das pessoas
que está comprando daí uma cenoura uma
senhora
o meia alisson para lá tá tudo errado e
aí eu comecei a pensar um pouco mais
sobre o lugar das pessoas no sistema de
notar e veja só a gente se preocupa hoje
tanto é com obesidade doença
relacionados a estilo de vida as
consequências ambientais do que comemos
as conseqüências econômicas para onde
está indo o dinheiro que investimos na
alimentação
as empresas que hoje financia campanhas
às vezes são grandes empresas
alimentícias que a gente está fazendo em
relação à comida que a gente faz
quem é que já postou
foto de comida numa rede social levanta
um todo mundo é todo mundo tem essa
possa aquela foto pornográfica da coisa
que a gente faz
quem é que conhece essa pessoa
todo mundo né o alex atala já virou pop
já é uma celebridade é uma figura
conhecida e well chefe por um lado isso
é bom mas por outro lado mostra o que
estamos valorizando hoje na nossa
cultura alimentar é o fetiche pelo pela
comida
você vê aparece com a mão não aparece
quem fez a comida de onde veio e pela
aquela pessoa que coloca dá o toque
final
pela proposta é bem simples
existem mil dietas tecnologias incríveis
várias várias balas de prata que vão
revolucionar o sistema alimentar mas
pelo elas começam com as pessoas começam
com pessoas como o tonel já manu que é
um casal bem jovem que largou a cidade
foram uma fazenda que foi dos ancestrais
e resolveram voltar a plantar reativar o
alambique e trazer para a cidade uma
cidade onde é que eles vão eles vão
comer fera começa com a catarina que
também já trabalhou inclusive agora
trabalha com pequenos produtores
desidratando os produtos e oferecendo na
feira
essa evolução em começa também com
antônio um artista que por acaso começou
é a trabalhar numa fazenda de café está
convertendo toda a sua plantação de um
café incrível pra para o sistema
florestal a revolução também continua
com pessoas como fabrício um produtor
que também largou a vida na cidade de
advogado para trabalhar cultivando
cogumelos no sítio e essas pessoas que
para não são apenas os empreendedores
são ativistas são pessoas que estão
realmente se mobilizando
são pessoas que acreditam no potencial
da comida como uma forma de
transformação pessoal e coletiva e da
sociedade do mundo que a gente vive
se juntaram na iniciativa que eu criei
junto com mais dois viciados possa dizer
também o bruno henrique
a gente começou a junta local há mais ou
menos dois anos na comunidade de
pequenos produtores que têm o objetivo
de colocar em destaque os produtores de
encurtar a distância entre onde a comida
produzida e onde a comida consumida de
tentar repensar o protagonismo das
pessoas o espaço nossas práticas em
relação à comida que a gente faz bem
se a senhora está morrendo vamos trazê
lo de volta mas com algumas mudanças nas
feiras vamos pessoas e lugares locais
vibrantes precisam ter a presença dos
próprios produtores precisam refazer o
elo que a gente perdeu que os
supermercados tentou repor ou através de
uma embalagem bonitinho através de um
digo bonitinho através de uma campanha
bacana como chefe incrível
a feira é um lugar vibrante a feira
lugar que ocupa a cidade a feira é uma
plataforma de baixo custo que a
pretendente a democratização dos
alimentos
a gente também tem a nossa própria
versão zinho do supermercado que é o que
ele chama de sacola virtual que é um
sistema em que os produtores participam
da oferta os seus produtos e fazer as
próprias entregas ajudam a organizar e
os consumidores também têm um papel
ativo mundo lá buscando participam desse
processo ea gente sem querer virou uma
comunidade um coletivo que se reúnam
para discutir várias coisas para se
mobilizar para ajudar o outro
isso tem dois anos é que existimos e
desde então a gente já realizou mais de
40 feiras em toda a cidade não só na
zona sul do rio de janeiro
já realizamos mais de 40 sacolas
virtuais
a gente já deve ter alimentado mais de
500 mil pessoas ao longo desse tempo e
principalmente a gente tá eu ando uma
nova geração
de de empreendedores ea gente está
tentando justamente recolocar o
protagonismo das pessoas do espaço assim
como tonel fabrício catarina o antônio
já somos mais de 200 produtores ea
questão aqui não é só a produção é
também o papel de cada um de vocês que
estão aqui refletindo justamente nisso
onde é que eu estou comprando mais
alimentos onde estou é consumido nos
alimentos
eu tô comprando de pessoas
eu tô comendo com pessoas ou não
qual o impacto disso na minha cidade no
ambiente no mundo que eu acredito ser
melhor e eu acredito muito nisso eu
acredito na comida é um amor na comida
como uma expressão desse amor dessa
vontade de transformação de um mundo
melhor para as gerações futuras para os
nossos filhos e para a preservação da
raça humana pra nossa hiperbólico então
o que fica aqui como lição comprar o
empreendedorismo que foi pra quem
chamaram aqui hoje não sei talvez muito
bem porque quer dizer não me considero
um empreendedor mas simplesmente uma
pessoa que viu um problema e tentou
resolver nesse caminho conseguiu teve a
sorte de deter companhia de várias
outras pessoas apaixonadas pela comida e
queriam transformar o mundo através da
comida que eu tenho pra quem quer
empreender hoje é essa que o futuro não
está nas empresas está nas pessoas nas
formas como elas vão interagir com a
comida
então é isso a gente é o convido vocês a
participarem desse movimento e que esse
movimento seja feito uma feira de cada
vez
obrigado